spectra partitioning meditation this
bunch of covers are a soft knower such a
Nicole of Elia Resnick Stein who is in
the audience and their evening garden
who is also in the audience ready and
this is the title is spectral
partitioning chromatics
it's also about nearest neighbor search
you know it's a workshop on that
so has to relate and I guess it feels
weird to define nearest neighbor search
at a workshop whose title includes that
but I'll do it anyways you know maybe
there is online audience and also to set
up notation so I'll talk you know from
about approximate nearest neighbor
search where it's a data structure
question where we have endpoints in a
general metric space X and I'll return
to the question of what is this metric
space X in a second and we'll denote
this by P in a bunch of points and we
need to pre-process so that we can
answer queries where we have two
parameters the approximation which will
denote by C bigger than 1 and distance
threshold are determined to think about
this as we want points which are within
distance we want to report points of in
distance R so okay define visit the
query means that we get a new point Q is
that point so that we can report any
point within distance R that would be
the exact near neighbor the approximate
version says that assuming that varies
appointive in distance R from our query
we want to report anything which is
within distance here ok so if there is
no point which is within distance R from
cube and the data structure can do
anything it wants but if there exists a
point within this since our bandit
should do for something which is from a
ball a little bit larger by a factor of
C ok so this is the standard definition
of the approximate near neighbor for a
particular different threshold are so
you know
in it kind of the correspondence to
practice is that we report points which
are at least this similar right where
this is concrete threshold and it has
tight connection to be nearest neighbor
where we want to report the approximate
the point which is within whose distance
is even faster see of the point which is
the closest to the query point Q okay
but I mean he'll focus on this near
neighbor where we have this threshold
are just because you know it's usually
this easier to design algorithms or at
least solvents of our time for these for
this problem okay
and the main parameters here were kind
of the usual trade-off is to obtain you
know approximation versus space there's
a square time you know usually kind of
the biggest trade-off or the usual ten
to the biggest tension is between
approximation where the space and
correct time at least this is what will
be the focus of today okay so this is
standard definition and just you know
quickly to go through enough you know
the main points or remain kind of set up
of this problem ask questions why why
approximate wide are focusing on
approximate nearest neighbor search well
I mean here we are focusing on the high
dimensional case in high dimensional
case the exact nearest neighbor search
is usually hard so depending you know
depending on the exact model you know
what exactly it means hard one can do
for example you know based iver some
data structure lower bounds or say based
on surf you so on strongly special time
hypothesis other additional assumptions
you can pretty much exclude non-trivial
algorithms for high dimensional
situation okay so okay so what does it
mean so here I'm saying like you know
how there's no problem what does has a
national mean will usually think of
dimension as being at least logarithmic
in the number of points so you know it's
at least log and we've you know very lot
a little bit more than log and si okay
so but what is dimension right so at the
moment I said metric space you know what
is the dimension of metrics
well so how do you define dimension so
first of all you know oftentimes central
you know from the rest of the talk
pretty much I'll talk about metrics
which are defined on on real space with
D dimensional real space bottom is where
alternative notions of dimension for
example doubling dimension of a metric
space and so forth okay
but again here we'll talk about a metric
spaces on D dimensional areal spaces and
you think of dimension as being you know
again a little bit more than logarithmic
and then we'll also think of dimension
as being smaller than polynomial in and
in the in the data set just because you
know in when it's bigger than kind of
our types of all good he can okay and
most importantly what we'd like to
obtain is the dependence on dimension
which is polynomial okay as opposed to
exponential in dimension algorithms so
this is you know this is the set up and
this is Vico okay so now you know let me
kind of you know get a little bit more
specific now so which metrics to use
okay so this is you know a little bit
more specific to this talk so which
might talk to you and this is kind of
you know the main question that I mean
we are looking at and in this line of
work and in general kind of you know
from kind of application perspective you
know you want to use nearest neighbor
search under a metric which captures the
semantic similarity alright so one of
the you know main applications for
nearest neighbor search is similarity
search you know given you know you have
a data set of objects you're given any
object you want to find similar ones you
know perhaps for labeling classification
so you want you know when you're
comparing objects you know images or
texts right you want to define on these
objects certain kind of distance so that
it it captures the semantic similarity
with you know what you mean with objects
to be similar to capture it well at the
same time you know of course you can
create pretty crazy distances but it you
know it's very easy to
create once which would be you know very
hard to design albums for at least
non-trivial algorithms and you know
there is you know tension kind of what
you want to define some semantic
similarity defined distance function but
has you know captured semantic
similarity so semantic similarity and
most efficiently tractable a meaning in
in practice oftentimes you know what
what you'll do is that you'll define a
simple distance function which for which
there is algorithms and you know this
would be a pretty important kind of
consideration so I mean here we kind of
want to step back from kind of from that
general approach and say okay can we
design the receiver search for more
general matrix can we build kind of more
of a theory of nearest neighbor search
for more general classes of matrix okay
I should mention you know some examples
of metric spaces and you know this is
not quite in order of hardness but you
know roughly I mean of course can some
of the easiest easiest high dimensional
spaces are hanging space or clean space
but they're kind of more specialized
distance distances for example earth
over distance which is kind of more
specific to image vision but you can
also imagine other distances for example
spectral norm for distance between
matrices distance is one of them but you
know it would go over in second line so
yes I'll actually get to that distance
that you know the last slide actually
but it's at a distance as well though I
mean it's all examples here on North
Jetty distance is not a norm and I'll
get two norm there's just no norms later
in the talk okay so the general goal of
you know is okay oh you know all this
rambling of mine is pretty much to get
to the to this goal but what is you know
what is the goal of our project is to
try to understand or classify nearest
the complexity of nearest neighbor
search as a function of a metric okay so
so critical perspective you can think
about this question as you know what
property of a metric space make it hard
or easy for nearest neighbor search okay
and from practical perspective I mean
the reasoning or the motivation comes
with if we managed to design nearest
neighbor search but is you know somehow
works for a generic metric you know
maybe somehow the complexity of it
depends on the property of a metric but
the algorithm is kind of more generic
that applies to many metrics at the same
time then I mean it must be a certain
kind of universal algorithm for nearest
neighbor search with somehow adapts to
the Java metric and this is important in
practice because oftentimes you know
you'll design a particular metric for
comparing your objects and you know it's
often to tinker with it you know modify
it a little bit here two bit there and
you don't want to say that suddenly the
geometry of the space changes a little
bit and you have to redesign the
algorithm from scratch it would be nice
to have an algorithm that somehow you
know is resilient to these changes okay
you know hopefully answering or
approaching this goal will you know give
such a neighbor solution okay and let me
give you know what I would call not
quite solution I mean it's solution in
our situations but something that not
gives doesn't quite give a solution for
this particular goal and this is
designing approximate nearest neighbor
search if for any metric with small dog
in dimension okay so this is line of
work but applies for any metric so it
says that its nearest neighbor search
where you know the only information I
give from get from a metric is that I
can ask black box black box what is the
distance between these two points okay
given ID so of two points there is a
black box that says what is the distance
so assuming that this metric space has
load up in dimension there are
algorithms that started with work of Ken
Carson but also appeared in our papers
were improved in other papers we
obtained algorithms that work with this
black box and so in the sense we work
for any metric okay the caveat is and
whitie not quite a solution for us is
that the algorithms will
exponential dependence on this doubling
dimension okay so while we work for a
new metric the dependent on dimension
you know doubling the mission here
because it's a generic metric will be
exponential what we want we want two
polynomial dependence on dimension okay
so you think about this is a kind of
generic algorithm for up for nearest
neighbor search but it is for low
dimensional spaces we want to do this
for high dimensional spaces yeah I mean
the we won't put a number of dependence
and dimension we'll see what is
dependence on n you know whatever is the
best dependence on n we can get the
better right and in general it will be a
trade-off between approximation and
because this dependence on and in space
and credit okay I'll give an example
pretty much on the next slide so you
know let's see what you know the type of
hubs we can get for high dimensional
case in general and the simplest case on
the high dimensional case the simplest
one is basically I wanna know two matrix
norms and you know this is something
that has been studied a lot and
basically most of the nearest neighbor
search data structures which have been
designed so find the literature are for
hemming and Euclidean spaces and you
know it started with locality sensitive
hashing which was the first algorithm
should obtain polynomial dependence on
dimension and I guess you know the later
work kind of it gave the you know best
known algorithms for l1 and l2 case are
these donnaught is called now dependent
data dependent hashing and the type of
bounds that you get is that the space
will be + 2 1 plus Epsilon query time is
n 2 Epsilon so small polynomial loss in
space and small polynomial in query time
and the approximation you know is
something that depends on epsilon so
freak linear space the best dependence
is pretty much one over root epsilon ok
right so in in a sense if you want to do
this for general spaces for general high
dimensional spaces we don't really hope
to do much better than this but can we
do this for general spaces for general
high dimensional spaces so this is the
question okay so so general norms so
sorry for it so let's focus you know
okay talking about you know matrix is
hard so let's you know focus a little
bit more narrow down a little bit more
let's talk about norms okay so what can
we do for norms so let's say we have d
dimensional real space and we consider
all possible norms okay which is
subclass of matrix what can you do there
so then we can do the following and of
you know a naive application of of Jones
ellipsoid theorem which says that any
dimensional space is within route factor
of root dimension from d-dimensional
euclidean space okay so pictorially you
know maybe in convex geometry we have
seen the statement more like in this way
but any symmetric context by DK there
exists an ellipsoid II so let's say this
rectangle is our context by the key but
it's an ellipsoid which is inside this
context body and root this can involve
is the website captures this context
plan okay so this is this is the theorem
and we can use this theorem to get some
algorithm for any node so in particular
using this theorem directly by the veces
tight bound is ready even for you know
spaces like a 1 or infinity so you know
and I call this kind of baseline
approximate nearest neighbor search for
norms you know which precedes the
embedding in particular this Johnson
episode so what it immediately implies
is the following right and you know this
this theorem is implied by you know
taking your norm applying the embedding
from the previous slide and then using a
standard algorithm for nearest neighbor
search are in Euclidean space
okay so what we obtained is space will
be again and to one perceptual on query
time will be n to epsilon the
approximation will be now root D by
Epsilon okay where root epsilon is the
trade-off you know there's a space and
query time that we get for Euclidean
space and rudy we get from mapping
linear space sorry mapping the general
norm into a clean air space when you say
D dimensional known space what is the
dimension of the null space why is the D
it's defined on Rd so this is our metric
the dimensional real space with some
known so these not a is not interest by
the non dimensional norm you know sorry
I'm saying the video D was not induced
by the norm itself in just a little D of
there are D yes yes okay
so so this is okay I mean this is kind
of you know what you can get using kind
of standard for known theorems and you
know this leads me to our results so
this is you know this is the baseline
algorithm for approximate nearest
neighbor search that I just mentioned in
previous slide
I'm fixing epsilon to be a constant you
know just to simplify format here so our
paper and you know this is what I mostly
focus in this talk shows it for any
general norm so any norm defined on a D
dimensional real space we can get an
approximate nearest neighbor search will
have the same space and query time n to
1 plus Epsilon space and to epsilon
query time and which achieves
approximation order log D so an
exponential improvement from this result
one caveat is that we don't quite get an
data structure we get what is called a
cell probe a data structuring bicep
remodel as in
the query time this end of our epsilon
query time is not the total time that
takes to run the query the query time
it's actually more but the number of
probes into the data structure is n to
power epsilon is so put differently what
it means is that we take n point data
set with reprocess it we construct
something which we write out in memory
which takes n - 1 perceptual in space
and when the query time we get a query
point and what we count only is how many
times I look at this memory I might do
much more computation but you know this
is how many memory probes I'll do okay
and you know obviously this is you know
not you know it's not real data
structure so in in kind of fill our next
work and this is what Ilya will talk in
the next talk we can improve we can get
a real data structure where n to power
epsilon is the actual query time with
the data structure the approximation
goes to 2 - root log D okay so somewhere
between per logarithmic and supportin on
you and so this is this is V results for
general norm for but it is a general
technique that can be applied to many
norms and for many norms one can apply
one can get better bounds and for
example for LP spaces where think of P
as being big urban - let's say as well
as for shuttle norms so norms are
matrices one can obtain approximation
which is order P I should say for LP
this improves upon you know efficient
nearest neighbor search approximately
reasonable search algorithms that got
exponential in P approximation before
and in particular for spectral norm this
is basically
chaton where p is equal to infinity one
can get approximation which is order log
D okay and this by mentioning is that
these are actual data structure it's not
just so pro there are questions so far
about the results it's for the rest of
the talk what what I'll do is I'll talk
about this general principle or you know
general approach to designing nearest a
research that gets us movies so probe
results and it depends on a property of
a metric but I'll define next and then
also how this property of a metric gives
rise to approximate nearest neighbor
search specific approximation to D so
you can have arbitrary here is this
business odious yeah this this result is
basically says that well shuttin
infinity is pretty much the same as
chaton log G of the constant factor you
know therefore you order log G this is
not but these approximation order log D
is necessary we don't we don't really
have a lower bound for general norm
profit no we have just our particular
approach to designing yes log D is
optimal but for data structures no I
mean in particular for an infinitive
approximation that a result of that
ranging from 98 say obtains is log D we
do not know whether for general north's
we can get lucky or not but our
particular approach gets lonely
actually
yes yeah so as in our approach an
affinity already we cannot beat love the
approximation even though in principle
there is another option that gets logged
on okay so if not let me talk about the
new approach right and this is where you
know the actual title of the talk comes
the spectral partitioning and it is you
know basically you know what what is our
new approach well I'll define a new
notion we call it cutting modulus it's a
well defined quantity for every metric
not just norm and we show that it
governs the complexity of approximate
nearest neighbor search so all those
results follow from you know obtaining
bounds on cutting discarding models and
you know as a point this kind of this
notion goes beyond obtains better
results and you can obtain through the
no metric embed next we see in 202 the
plinian space or or Hamming space which
were you know the usual approach is to
obtaining operations beyond l1 or l2 and
kind of another component and this is
pretty much you know connected to this
point how it governs the approximate
nearest neighbor search is that using
this notion we are showing a new
partitioning for for metric spaces which
is you know based on this notion of
cutting modules I should mention
especially for experts in the audience
you know this partitioning is not both
carving or at least we don't know to
show that both carving actually works
here it might just as well but it's not
ball carding which is a very classic way
to do partitioning then for example
optimal ogress freak Lydian space and so
forth okay so I'll define this cutting
modulus and you know there is anything
to get from this talk this is probably
you know the most important notion to
get from the talk and the solids okay
so again it is defined for a metric
space we denote it by
Greek letter for C it's a freaking
x-components
yeah I think we ran out of all the other
Greek letters by the time so okay so
this is this number disc C is it depends
on the metric and and on epsilon which
is some parameter so it is the following
the smallest number such as the
following calls for any graph so
consider any any graph but we embed into
our metric space M such that all the
edges have length at most R in this
matter okay so pictorially I mean it's
not quite equivalent but you can also
think the following I have my metric
space I put a bunch of points in this
metric space visible my vertices of the
graph I connect the vertices if they're
a distance that most are I should say
that this is such that for any are the
following cons okay so you know R is
this fresh hope that we care at the
moment okay so so you know it pretty
much saying okay consider a bunch of
points in the metric space built the are
near neighbor in his for these points
okay so all these edges are between
points which are distance at most R okay
so for any such graph with the draw
there are one of the following two must
hold our very exists a ball of radius
which is you know our parameter R times
this parameter cutting models in
particular see that captures let's say a
constant fraction of the points let's
say half of your points over a graph or
what is the number line
many months is it smallest not the
smallest see such a the following holds
so and and is the number of vertices of
this okay cough yeah okay or if this
doesn't hold when the graph must have an
epsilon sparse cut okay so for example
it is something like this there gives a
partition of a graph such that the
conductance is at most Epsilon
it looks like saying if you try to embed
an expander all the points have to be
close together right so in a sense
exactly so having she'd be very small
means that you cannot really embed the
expander into your graph that's that's a
very good intuition yes precision right
this means that if C is very small then
this means that if you have like a very
large expander when it the distances
must collapse because it doesn't have
that so as parts cut this means that
there exists a ball of radius which is
just a little bit more than the length
of the edges that captures you know big
fraction of the vertices this means that
you know most of the distances collapse
most important slide okay so okay let me
give a simple example you know hopefully
this will help a little bit for the
intuition so let's prove that see for a
real line so this is one dimensional
space you know for this parameter
epsilon the conductance is upper bounded
by 1 over epsilon up to constants okay
so here is the proof all right so we
have we have a graph right we have this
embedding right so this is the function
that map's vertices into real reals ok
so now we can write the definition of
lambda to the second largest eigenvalue
of the edges symmetric circuit graph and
you know if you write it in the you know
correct form this is what you'll get
right that the average squared distance
for two random points so this is a few
minus of e for two random points a
squared is upper bounded by 1 over 1
minus lambda 2 of a graph times the
average distance of the average squared
distance of the edges
okay this is you know this is the
definition of lambda 2 and and now what
I you know what I want to say is that
you know either there must be a small
ball that captures a high fraction of
the points and the radius of that ball
will be at most one over epsilon or
there is whatever is the sparse cut in
this graph ok so so we'll proceed from
here so first of all notice that I mean
we'll use the fact that the the all the
edges of the graph have distance at most
R so this means that the expected
squared length of the edges is at most R
square just because each of these is at
most R all right so now if it happens
that there is no ball of radius roughly
R by epsilon which contains Omega n
vertices this means that the average
distance this quantity must be at least
R by epsilon squared this is not true
when there is a ball of radius you know
basically by mark of the exist a ball of
radius R by epsilon which contains cost
a fraction of the vertices okay and now
you know we have R squared by epsilon R
by epsilon squared here we have you know
something that involves lambda 2 we have
R squared here you know just you know
doing you know immediate calculation
implies that 1 minus lambda 2 basically
the spectral graph of the graph is is
must be smaller than epsilon squared by
a constant factor now we cannot by
[ __ ] inequality this means that there
exists an epsilon sparse cutting this
graph and we've got basically our hours
for Scott
wherewhere is that here f is embedded so
you can think about f gives to every
vertex gives a real number
just because it's you know it's
something that fits on two lines on the
slave I mean you can prove a thing for
non regular graphs and stuff
so we'll see actually enter this picture
see this is co so what does say I
Burberry this a ball R times C right so
this is here so our tank 60 versus one
over epsilon more questions here okay
and once we've proven this we
immediately get the same statement for
equilibrium space as well this is
because a clean space is some of the
since L 2 squared is additive over
coordinates you know we have squares
here so we get exactly the same upper
bound on it so like yes
okay so this is okay this is for your
line for you clean space but you know
this is not why we're doing this you
know the question is okay how does it
how does it work for our gnomes okay so
first of all you know the cutting
modulus is well-behaved augering under
embeddings so in particular for example
if our metric space in doesn't well -
with distortion okay which is denoted as
C 2 of M then it is immediate to prove
that C too much by combining with the
previous slide but this C is upper
bounded by C - basically the best
distortion of an embedding in take
linear space but the point is that we
can but exceed for many norms is much
smaller than this bound when the best
distortion of embedding into Euclidean
space okay and you know over to suggest
it and it's related to you know how well
can we embed large expanders into our
metric okay so in particular you know
let me state some bounds for cutting
modulus fun ones so the baseline you
know again this is kind of by embedding
its media to get with this C for any D
dimensional space is a d-dimensional
norm is upper bounded by Rho G by
Epsilon
but it turns out that for North one can
get a much better bound one can get log
G maps on squared and this is a result
of a soft nor from about a year ago okay
so this is you know this is a
non-trivial theorem people in itself
it's
so and one can one can get better bounds
for special cases in particular for
pspace one can get water T by epsilon
models you know for PB given to these
this follows from work of mateship and
for for shuttin P one can also get
something like water P by epsilon and
this follows from works by Matuszak now
we're and and record did not improve
epsilon here yes I mean of course you
know now you know it's interesting to
get the tight bound by its own but you
know for approximate nearest neighbor
search but in in terms of C I don't know
if this is this bound is this dependence
on Neptune is tight or not actually is
it we don't know yeah but in terms of in
terms of dependence on work G and P here
these bounds are tight
for cutting windows
okay so this was this was cutting motto
so now let's show that you know
basically if you get a good bond and
Khattak Mantle's it implies a good
nearest neighbor search algorithm so
this is the fury of a kind of the more
algorithmic purium the main contribution
of the paper is to prove the following
theorem that says that for any metric
space there exists an randomized
approximately recent research data
structure which obtains approximation
upper bounded by C for this is for you
know for any epsilon C the function of
the tips alone after constant space will
be n - 1 plus order epsilon times
something which is polar logarithmic in
the size of the metric space and I
should mention that you know for D
dimensional in our spaces you can think
about you should feel you should replace
log X with D here
this will be polynomial in dimension and
the query procedure inspects and toward
there epsilon times again but normally
the dimension memory locations of the
data structure
okay so this is this is the theorem okay
and you know kind of the main message is
that if the space does not contain large
expanders meaning that C is relatively
small then approximate nearest neighbor
search is possible please for so probe
algorithms all right so so let me tell
you kind of you know how to obtain this
this theorem and little talk about this
core partitioning procedure so think
about the metric space you know defined
on a space X you know it's it's much
simpler for us to think of X as being in
a finite set and you know you can think
about this as being the size of the
space as being exponential dimension for
norms you know you start of course with
you know you set which is it has
infinite size but you can discretize and
you know do visual kind of reductions so
that you you really have to consider on
a finite finite space X so we need the
following partitioning procedure to
build a collection F so f are sets on X
such that for any endpoint data set
called P we have the following
however exists a ball of radius a
separate for this data set P I variable
exists a ball of radius R times C U
which contains many points Omega n
points so this means that all within
this ball of radius all the points are
you know the distance roughly R times C
so kind of close to each other is six
more okay so it looks something like
this or if if this doesn't hold okay so
you know to connect to this collection
there exist a distribution D of cuts
that partition the point set roughly
evenly okay so this means that so
something like this so somehow
partitions into let's say purple and
green subsets which are roughly
each of them is of size Omega n such
that the following codes for any two
points X 1 X 2 which are closed so a
distance that most are the probability
that I cut chosen randomly from this
distribution over you know nearly even
cuts will separate X 1 X 2 is upper
bounded by Epsilon okay so this again
says there exists there exists a
collection it's so kind of ground set of
sets such that for any data set point
unless we exist a ball that contains
many points again the point set is
relatively nearby to each other there
exist a distribution over near balanced
cuts over P such that any closed point
is separated you know when we choose a
cart randomly from this distribution D
is these probabilities upper bounded by
epsilon the distribution this
distribution is defined on F
distribution D is on the cuts from F as
in this is the set of allowed cuts okay
and the point being that the the size
the number of allowed cuts is very small
in particular log of F is order of D
cube yes so F is the set of allowed cuts
okay and distribution D is just saying
how many probabilities here so in
particular log of F is polynomial in
dimension and D is over D by epsilon
says from F in particular which means
the distribution D can be described with
polynomial in dimension sighs so
description complexity of this
distribution D is small
so this way yourself probe versus
algorithm talk yes yes so you know this
is the core partitioning that were that
we are getting and you know it turns out
that this is enough for approximately
receiver search using more relatively
standard now standard techniques okay
and you know just to you know say
something kind of about connection
between cutting models in obtaining this
co partitioning the cutting modulus says
the following that we can find Socratic
models being small this means that we
can find an epsilon sparse cut in a
graph with short edges and where all the
vertices are separated by C so this
means that there is no small ball this
means that you know versus separated so
for any graph that satisfies this
property must have an epsilon sparse cut
so this is something that we are given
from the proprietary metric right this
is what it means for cutting models to
be small what we want to get this is the
partitioning that is sufficient for
nearest neighbor search is to say we
want a random partition but is good for
every pair of closed points with goodish
probability Epsilon and the description
complexity of this random partition is
relatively small okay about to finish
and you know how do we go go from here
to here this is essentially minimax long
enough at it so it is duality in the
spirit of minimax cerium and to go from
left to right we applied this even most
pictures where it's update method you
know it's actually to multiply w
algorithms nested in each other and you
know we need to use multiple it avoids
update it specifically to get this small
description complexity
so in the interest of time let me just
quickly kind of give advertisement for
the next talk so the cuts the
algorithmic aspect so what is so what is
the issue why do we get the
self-propelled version
well the question is how do we check on
which side of a cut we are right so the
cutting modulus guarantees us that there
exists a you know unless the points are
you know clustered there must be a cut
in the our graph that we consider and
how do we check on which side of the cut
we are so we have a bunch of points we
are guaranteed with there exists a small
cutting modulus means that there exist
some cut that partitions you know the
points which corresponds to the
partition of the graph but the issue is
that this cut comes from second a
conductor this this comes from applying
chiggers inequality and it's there is no
upper structure you know these are some
crazy graphs on one on the entire metric
space and there is no upper structures
so this means that the partition that we
get on the points may be arbitrary so
there is no so the cuts can't have very
complex boundary and there is no clear
out Brijnath tool to compute on which
side of the body cut you are so what we
really need is that if graph is embedded
into metric metric or normed space and
has small C when there is actually a
geometrically organically nice parts cut
and you know an example of a nice parts
cut is something that looks like this
particularly it's a coordinate cut and
for our P one can always find a
coordinate cut in fact that obtains this
C upper bounded by order okay
so peaceful and the same for certain P
so you know this is something that
you've mentioned a little bit in the
next talk and you know I'll conclude
here so again the main point or
remaining that I wanted to say about
here is cutting modulus which is genetic
recipe from you know going from by the
static modulus arose from the fury of
nonlinear spectral gaps but I suppose
suffer was developing
for a few years now and so this diesel
it's approximately very simple data
structure algorithms and the main
questions and that remain is first of
all to get time efficient data structure
for any norm achieving log deal
approximation so going from cell probe
to an actual algorithm so in the next
talk you will see you know step towards
their obtaining a bound which is
somewhere between four locations in
polynomial another question that we
don't know - you know how to approach at
the moment is to obtain polynomial
pre-processing time so overall our
current algorithms have exponential
pre-processing time even for spaces like
LP and another question is to obtain
cutting modulus to obtain better bounds
and cutting modulus for concrete spacing
clay like any distance or passage time
metric manifold you know a very nice
important metrics that one cares about
the next talks in just a few minutes if
there's a quick question to ask Alex
otherwise well restaurateurs
try to buy us more questions during the
next time
[Applause]